[موسيقى]
يريد ان يقول بوتين ان اسرع لن يقتصر على
مواجهه في اوكرانيا وانما نرى هنا هيا
بيلاروس وهذه الدول حلف الاطلسي طبعا
فنلندا وسويد هم في طريقهم للانضمام لكن
عندما ينشر هذا السلاح هنا طبعا هناك دول
حفر الاطلسي مواجهه مباشره وبالتالي رساله
مدى المواجهه سيتسح حتى او احتمال ان
يتسماد المواجهه حتى ابعد من اوكرانيا
لماذا اقول اقول انه مجرد تحذير حتى الان
وليس بالضروره تهديد التهديد يعني نحن
اقرب الى التنفيذ ان اردت لماذا اتحدث عن
تحذير اولا لان روسيا تمتلك على اراضيها
ما يكفي من هذه الاسلحه ان ارادت
استخدامها وتمتلك على اراضيها صواريخ
وطائرات وقذائف قادره على ايصالها للدول
التي تريدها هناك دول من حيث الاطلس
الحدود الروسيه ليس في حاجه الى نشر هذا
هذه الاسلحه على الاراضي بيلاروس لكي تهدد
ان اردت وبالتالي
لديها رغبه في التنفيذ الان هي قادره على
التلويح بالقول ان استخدم كذا سنستخدم
السلاح النووي التكتيكي ما هو السلاح
النووي التكتيكي حتى الناس تعرف عن ماذا
يتحدث السلاح النووي التقليدي يمكن ان
يفجر مدينه كامله هذا هو الذي رايناه
هيروشيما ونجازاكي ان اردت لكن مع الزمن
الانسان تفوق على نفسه في الدمار ان اردت
واستطاع ان ينتج اسلحه نوويه محدوده
التاثير بدل ان تفجر المدينه يمكن ان تفجر
موقع عسكري موقع قيادي وبالتالي القدره
حجم السلاح والقدره التدميريه محدوده لكن
يبقى انه سلاح نووي لان له اثار تاثير على
البشر وعلى البيئه ايضا وبالتالي ما يقوله
الروس الان نحن
تنقلوننا الى مرحله جديده هذه المرحله
يمكن ان نستخدم فيها السلاح اناوي لكن
اقول مره اخرى تبدو لي رساله تحذيريه لانه
اراد التنفيذ هو يملك فعلا السلاح على
اراضيه ويمكن ان يصله الاماكن التي يريدها
حتى عن طريق صواريخ اسكندر مثلا وليس في
حاجه الى نشرها في بيلاروسيا ومن يريد ان
يهدد وينفذ سريعا لا ينتظر اربعه اشهر حتى
يتم بناء مخازن لتخزين هذا السلاح على
الاراضي بيلاروس التدريب سيتم قريبا
الطائرات صحيح جهزت لكن الطائرات والتدريب
يحتاجون الى السلاح والسلاح لن يصل ويكون
فيها المخازن الا في شهر تموز وهذا ليس
سلوك من يهدد انه قريب ان ينفذ وانما يحذر
ان صعدتم سنفتح الباب لتصعيد اكبر ماذا عن
اليورانيوم المنظم خالد
موضوع اخر هو علميا او دوليا ان اردت لا
يوجد تعريف له على انه سلاح نووي لكن هو
مشتق من عمليه تخصيب اليورانيوم ويتمتع
بكثافه عاليه تمكنه من ان تصنع منه ذخيره
قادره على اختراق الدروع لماذا لا يصنف
على انه سلاح نووي لانه لا ينفجر ان اردتي
لكنه قادر على اختراق الدروع يستخدم ايضا
لتدعيم هذه الدروع لتكون لها قدره على
التصدي للصواريخ لكن بعض العلماء
يصنفون هذا اليورانيوم والمنظم على انه
نوع من اسلحه الدمار الشامل لماذا لانه
عندما يقوم
باستهداف او خرق مكان معين واشعال في هذا
المكان يفعل او يتسبب فيما يسمى بالغبار
الذري الذي ان ترسب او لامس
طعام المياه استنشقه انسان يبدا بعمليه
تدمير داخل جسم الانسان
وراينا في حرب الخليج الاولى عام 91 وفي
حصار الفلوجه بعد ذلك في العراق اثار نسبه
الاصابه بالسرطان والامراض السرطانيه
والتشوهات الجسمانيه بسبب استخدام الجيش
الامريكي لهذه الاسلحه ففي هذه الحاله نحن
نتحدث عن مجرد تحذير هذا يبدو لي تحديد
مباشر بانه ان قمتم باستخدام هذا السلاح
لانه استخدام هذا السلاح سيكون قوه
تدميريه كبيره على القوات الروسيه على
الارض وبالتالي روسيا ستكون مهدده
تعاني من خسائر وتلد سيكون هناك رده فعل
سيضطر في النهايه الروس الى استخدام سلاح
مشابه خاصه ان الدول تعمدت ان اردت رغم
تحذير العلماء تعمدت عدم وصفه بان سلاح
تدمير شامل يمكن للروس ان يستخدمه مثل هذا
السلاح هو في هذه الحاله التدمير سيكون
كبير بين الطرفين وحتى الجنود حتى
الامريكيون الذين استخدموا هذا السلاح في
الحرب الخليج الاولى عانى منهم عشرات
الالاف من اعراض مرضيه اختلفت التقرير
اسبابها لكن البعض ارجاح لهذا السلاح في
النهايه الروسي يكونون مضطرين ان اردتي
وسيكون لهم الحجه على ان يستخدموا نفس
السلاح وسيكون قوه تدميريه اكبر
والقوه المضره على حتى الجنود نسبه اكبر
وعندها سنكون انتقلنا من حرب تقليديه
عاديه اقتربنا اكبر بشكل اكبر ان اردتي
الى امكانيه استخدام السلاح النووي
التكتيكي وهنا ننتقل الى مرحله جديده في
الصرع خالد شكرا جزيلا لك